a new testing facility for one of the
areas of the country
worst hit by covid19 and a new
technology
because the government's second contact
tracing app is being trialled here
although it's not clear it actually
works
what we don't know is the difference the
app has made
and that's why i think it's really
important for those responsible running
the app
it's not you aren't able to release the
data it's they've got to be the
government
share that data with us because i'm keen
to make sure
during this pilot phase we learn the
lessons otherwise what is the point of
having a pilot
those aren't the only questions about
test and trace
as our own kay burley told the health
secretary this morning
i put my postcode in and the the website
app
and it's a hundred miles i have to
travel to have
a test that's not satisfactory is it
that's rubbish in fact
it's one of the reasons that we're we're
investing so much more
in new testing and these new
technologies can really change that
because at the moment the system the
system works well of course there's
operational challenges from time to time
but it works well
and we're finding a higher and higher
proportion of the people in the country
who have coronavirus but
that's not what today's data shows in
the seven
worst hit areas in the country test and
trace is barely reaching
half the context of people who test
positive in the community
so-called non-complex cases
in blackburn with darwin it reaches 47
of contacts
leicester 53 and in bradford just 43
percent
the basic problem for the government is
that they're very good at contact
tracing in places like this
hospitals where everyone is on hand but
not so good at doing it in the community
and the trouble is that these days most
cases are in the community
and that's why tests and traces numbers
are going down
step two chew with your mouth
as if you're eating to gather up spit
the government is
pinning its hopes on better tests today
it announced 500 million for further
trials of a saliva one
and two others it says can get results
back in 20 minutes
the david family was part of the initial
trial as soon as we got up
we all came down into the kitchen with
our tubes um
got our teaspoons out followed the
instructions and essentially spat into a
pot
um sealed it back up and that was it
done
it's a positive step but it doesn't
matter how many people you test
if you can't also reach their contacts
with cases at their highest level since
may that
will be what's worrying the government
roland manthal
sky news